hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm a big dumb dummy apparently
because holy crap I was wandering around
outside there forever until this hint
popped up and it was like you want to
move the cart your stupid a-hole and I
was like cart what Kurt oh man so yeah
so I'm I'm the biggest dummy dummy that
ever lived because I also like I tried
to restart my game I tried to restart
the computer I tried to backtrack a bit
and I was at a total loss and was about
to look up a walkthrough or something
and then a little hint popped up at home
I'm just so stupid I got so focused on
her saying like can you get me up there
that I was like huh I got a booster up
there somehow with my power legs and
arms but no apparently that was totally
wrong and I'm just a big giant idiot so
now that we know that I'm big giant it
let's upgrade our weapons and uh moping
around we got to go got to go all right
what do we want upgrade here um I'm
thinking that we still want to keep our
trusty shotgun nice and upgrade so let's
get these cheapo upgrades right here ah
da bing bada boom do see I don't think
we have enough supplements to do
something I want to get weapons way and
I only need five more to be able to get
that so that's next on my list um could
use a med kit keeping my craftable up
and ready to go I apologize if my voice
is a little rough I just woke up a
little bit ago so I'm not quite warmed
up for this so hopefully no screaming is
involved for the next part
Oh
there's a couple of days off
whatever man no food Oh pair shoes yeah
then what was the point
besides being giant [ __ ] you got a
guy strapped with chains to the front of
your car you're a giant dick that's what
you is
that's all you is all right whatever
whatever whatever whatever whatever yeah
yeah it's the harsh reality of this
place bridge I mean not everyone's got
to be an evil bastard but some people
really take a liking to that type of
lifestyle when everything goes to hell I
don't understand why people just don't
work together because it seems like
there wouldn't be enough human resources
to go around I mean yeah food might be
scarce and stuff but no reason to start
murdering everybody right right right
crap I don't have any bricks all right
whatever
Ellie yeah you just keep standing right
there sweet they're going right by oh
that's good hearing them talk yeah I'm
just saying ah early that's so sweet
okay okay whatever you say I like I'm
Joe I don't need no compliment to go on
through life it's my new Joel voice is
what I'm gonna do from now on
y'all ready for it y'all like my Let's
Plays because of mine my voice is for my
characters right y'all go go go go go
get it now my name's Joel I'm gonna beat
the crap out of okay never mind
I'm not gonna do that I'm not being
serious I'm just joking calm down okay
moving forward whoo yeah
I'm trying not to avoid any collectible
because I really want the rest of that
supplements because I want to get the
weapons way perk which seems like you
guys were telling me it was a really
good one to have because obviously it
means that when you're aiming you don't
have to f up as much okay that's not go
hello see you guy out there shoot him
see if he stops moving I'm not gonna
trust my aim I know my aim is to
scheisse to hit a guy like that from
that far away okay I don't see I hear a
bunch of voices I know it wasn't that
guy up at the top there and I see some
booby traps like over here which I
definitely don't want to get in trouble
with or that guy up there go sir why I
can go around to get into that yeah I
think so
just got to be very careful very careful
oh oh he stopped which means that I can
peg him maybe
scheisse boom did I get him I didn't get
him oh I thought I got that I'm just not
as good as I want to be and come Oh you
move yeah Matt see I'm just not as good
as I want to be with this thing damn it
Duke
mr. Abel over here not now ow ow ow
helmet - sorry I'm I'm royally buggering
this up sorry because my performance
yesterday was pretty good I wanted to
die there because I wanted to restart
that horrible thing because as soon as I
shot the guy up there I knew that
everything was gonna crap out on me okay
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
around and I'm gonna go in the building
this time and try to get inside okay
I'll try to get another shot on this guy
and then move in no no okay never mind
moving around because hopefully I can
get inside and start sneaking around
because that's what I want to do I want
to be a better sneaker I'm not good at
it but I'm trying like a shadow in the
night I have to personify what I want to
do which is stab them in the back so I
have to be the knife be the knife the
knife in the darkness
oh okay there's nothing just dramatic
music okay I'll go in from behind and
get him we can just figure out how to
get in this building here
scheisse okay here we go getting in here
like a shadow in the night
I am the knife in the darkness the sward
that guards that well doesn't got any
when I murder everyone in my sight
that's what I'm that's what my sword
does oh hello buddy let's see if I can
get you yeah really I do not need a
phone call right now though okay so that
guy's patrolling over there and this guy
is being a general dick but maybe I
could ship them real quick see ya if I
tag on and Fanny would have turned right
around so I got to find a way to get
these guys separated at the very least
yeah just stay low we're gonna be okay
we're gonna take these guys out and it's
gonna be no problem I'm actually gonna
get my brick out because that seems like
the best solution for this problem I
wish my melee weapon had more charges on
it wait that's a different guy there
seem to be three guys up here which way
is this guy going yeah okay I just said
no I said no people are calling me
randomly I'm so popular but I will not
stop I am recording a very important
game right now okay where's this guy
going where's he going where's he go you
might come down this way just
everybody's staying nice and calm if he
comes down I'm gonna get you're gonna
back up into this area damn it
Frick and frack well that's not good
damn it I'm trying to be careful trying
to be careful okay so there is a small
window of opportunity where that guy
comes down here that I can come up
behind him and stab him while those two
aren't looking so I'm gonna do that I'm
gonna shove them this time just because
I can sorry for the delays but I want to
be very patient very careful approach
this with caution to not alert
anyone come on over huh maybe you
thought you heard something over here
maybe there's something on that side of
the street that you can see from that
vantage point yeah maybe that's the case
maybe man maybe man
how about okay quick easy boys got him
now those are two over there then I need
to take care of could it get by this
wall okay I'm gonna get that guy first
so this guy goes way might be able to
just
one down
yeah just keep staring at that file
cabinet man OOP triangle yeah get him
get him get him get him get him get him
all right
that worked out pretty well I'm actually
pretty happy without that turned out
it's nice when a plan comes together
isn't it how many more are we dealing
with here hopefully not too many I think
I see I think I see a fade down since I
can go they used up a quite a bit of
shipping that's okay
anything down there okay I don't see
anyone this is going well so far
whoa whoa what the hell whoa whoa whoa
where did he come from whoa whoa what
the hell whoa Ellie yeah way to go Ellie
did you get that guy nicely done
yeah of great help jeez jeez jeez I know
what to say she's a powerhouse when it
comes to taking out these guys okay
don't need that I've got this cool
weapon with spikes on it that I can use
for some instant kills let me get my
brick out so I can brick these dicks and
move on with my life okay okay we got
one more guy down there he's on the
alert Ellie what you doing what you
doing Ellie all right is it just okay I
see two guys over there try no hang on
okay this guy seems to be just
patrolling over here I think I cleared
out most of the guys in this segment are
you oh hello
right behind you [ __ ] strangle this guy
oh crap all crap we didn't see anything
you don't see anything nothing weird
happening over here you see a thing
buddy hahaha how did that work out I
have no idea all right
it's weird it's whoa whoa whoa all right
yeah I could have gotten that guy I know
I could have there - over there
Ellie if you want to take one of these
guys out you're more than welcome to try
all right that guy's gonna stand around
for a bit and then wander off where's
the other guy I know there's two okay
here we go watch this move sick move bro
yeah that's how it's done
that's how it's done whoa okay where's
the other guy
okay I see you I don't have a brick but
I'm gonna take you out anyway hope he's
coming in
okay cool I'm gonna try to grab them if
I can't grab them oh that's right turn
around buddy
just walk that way that's where I am
that's where I am
that's the stuff yeah you heard a noise
over there dinger good job
yes I think that's the last one
was it yes yes I did it I did the whole
segment yes
oh not a shot was fired ah ha ha I did
that beautifully I don't think I
collected supplies oh hang on let me
look around for some supplies or if I
did collect supplies I didn't get very
many um yeah that's that's probably a
good idea oh okay what do we got in here
I'm talking about dad there replace my
brick um okay that's all in there I've
already gone the other buildings so I'm
assuming that there wasn't too much
laying around hopefully there'll be some
stuff over here what are we looking for
what the hell are we looking for anybody
want to tell me I'm still jazzed up that
I actually did that and effectively I
mean it took me a while because I was
trying to be very slow and careful about
it but I actually did it are you guys
proud of me you're probably not proud of
me you're probably way to go mark fire
everyone could have done that on their
first playthrough about five minutes in
but yo you being 200 shippable door
[Applause]
supplements supplements right pistol
ammo is full really I better use that
pistol then yeah pistol ammo looks full
okay um the other thing is I want to get
this weapon no weapon sway slam down
those supplements
I need more SHIVs Schwank
shoo wanky and then I need another med
kit and I'm getting pretty full up on
stuff but I need to use these Molotov
sand bombs more I know they're useful I
know they're very very useful but I
don't know for some reason I'm very
hesitant about using the grenades but I
will try in the future oh is this a tank
that I could take and commandeer that
would be awfully nice apparently a final
standoff between the soldiers and the
rebels and they won oh you want to say
something head out your barrels got a
losing side that's true
man they died a long time ago - don't
know Allie it's rough world really
teamwork teamwork you know I don't
imagine like during the first parts of
the epidemic the cities would be a
madhouse just with just with an
extraordinary amount of zombies
everywhere so how did they could how do
they get control of the zone in the
first place that's what I'd like to know
because it seems like it would be very
very difficult there that's not any
closer than it was before don't lie to
me you aren't you are a liar you're a
dirty dirty liar
you're lying to me and I want to find
more shippable doors because I liked I
liked finding that one that was very
nice okay any supplies over here
supplies some supplies [ __ ]
there's another what another what what
are you talking about there's another
what does he totally gut her by the end
I don't know you know focused all right
he just doesn't want to tell her about
his daughter yeah
Donna the wolf sir that liked a twilight
of this generation or this world's
movies dawn of the wolf Oh Oh Edward or
sorry Edie Ward Oh Ellie 20 are they
talking about how many guys I killed and
give this guy he seems to be segregated
from the group so he's obviously my
first target he's talking probably
wouldn't be a good idea to interrupt
their conversation and holy crap is that
truck gonna shoot at me oh oh oh oh oh
it's canned bacon I don't know how can
the bacon could be any sort of good okay
sounds like they're finally done talking
so I'm gonna just have to be very
careful what you looking at
what you doing what you doing there okay
hang on there was one off to the side
here that just seems to be standing
there so I'm gonna get him first
actually and then I'm going to kill the
rest of them on the deck what was the
[ __ ] was what what are you talking about
I hit a bush whoops my bad
what was that huh maybe you better
investigate further or not that's better
no bush no bush no bush no bush only
death awaits you
they'd probably strangle this one
that's how I would dive I got strangled
I just I just stand it as I'm gonna put
a little bit of it and then fall over
dead cuz I'm weird like that okay cuz
I'm strange
alright we got another guy kind of off
by himself hopefully when he turns
around here I'll be able to whoop in and
squeeze his head off ah crap
oh I thought oh hang on brick Oh take
that there we go one down
whoa I know Ellie I'm the best
I'm just so great at what I do and I'm
coming back to get this bottle because I
like I like that maneuver the brick and
death it's a good maneuver yo hello if
there he is okay so if he comes around
ya keep lookin that way buddy how are
you I don't know where are you whoa who
did that man I didn't even realize that
they knew where I was that wasn't good
oh oh
okay all right so uh I think there are
breaks in the shooting that I gotta move
with where they reload or something wait
there we go go go go go go duck I don't
think these cars would really do all
that much oh that was not the break
I think these cars would do that much to
protect me if this was really a
situation hello laughs a brick yes
thankfully I do I'm gonna brick the [ __ ]
out of you get ready get ready buddy oh
that is a good move I like that move I'm
using that move from now and fill
forever
ducking in this room checking down
grabbing this stuff full of explosives
can I make any more hang on I got a
craft for a second um I could get these
smoke bombs but then again I don't
really know what the smoke bombs do or
having used I mean hopefully [ __ ] I got
a smoke I'm not gonna throw a smoke bomb
in his face I want to let's gear up I
got a trophy hooray for me good job mark
mark hurry that's like the first trophy
I've ever gotten in this game you know
that that thing tears me apart so I
can't risk taking some fire from that
[ __ ]
whoop go go go come come get my bottle
okay whose move I think I'm in cover
whoa ah crap
I meant to throw whoops maybe this will
help me damn it and it won't help me
there
you're gonna get the old-fashioned gun
treatment that's not a gun boom shot yes
go now go go go go
sweep what the hell I did not expect
that
close the door Ellie that thing is I
think is very intent on getting me Oh
startling all right okay what have we
got here
flies supplies supplies no supplies all
right supply supplement something
something something nothing really
nothing huh
oh yes not okey-dokey let's go then
oh good in fact way I thought it was
gonna keep shooting at me from here
goody goody gumdrops we're gonna get
away we're gonna survive to live another
day survive to fight another day
whatever the expression is okay come on
come on Joe come on Joe all right in you
go all right all right all right all
right all right no I promise to stop
saying that which I will break my
promise forever and ever and ever I
never had ever had never had never never
I'm really I'm really jazzed up because
I'm actually playing well I think you
guys let me know if I'm playing up to
your expectations but I think I'm doing
better I'm doing much better aren't I am
I not I'm probably not you guys are
probably like uh-huh I think he's
actually playing good whoa do I go on
the ledger drop down I think I go on the
ledge that looks like a long fall to
some sharp steel rebar okay okay
okey-dokey whatever you say man swoop
swing from right you don't mess with
Joel yeah okay kid just take it easy
it's all right they're not the bad guys
yeah we're not who are you why did you
have a kid with you two
it seems weird click an exact parallel
trying to kill you yeah I thought you
were one of them too and I saw you
okay don't even notice they don't keep
kids around yeah
survival of the fittest you're bleeding
interesting this is so weird
it's like an exact parallel what's going
on here I think I cut your name was Joel
Ellie how many are with you
they're all dead hey we don't know that
we're a bunch of us more tourists but
I'm guessing an idea of entering the
city you're surprised those [ __ ]
ambushed us scattered us now it's all
about getting out of [ __ ] hole
okey dokey we can help each other oh we
can we she's right is she is she really
we gotta hide I'm not too far from here
be safer if we chat there okay whatever
you say man why are you out here then
take us there so not sure if I trust
these guys me I mean they got a kid with
him it's got to be some sort of burden
of responsibility don't worry I would
have probably done the same thing oh
look they're communicating from what did
I get molotovs hell yeah that means I
really need to start using them more
because I love my molotovs and now they
have a bigger splash radius so they can
destroy him or her no the kids room can
I find any supplies in the kids room a
bottle of booze under the kids bunk bed
careful
okey dokey whatever you say man I will
follow your lead to the ends of the
earth when you're done I promised
someone I'd look at ya not my daughter
tell me Shiva beador yeah oh love it I
love it so much
oh yeah oh look at all the supplies I'm
getting too excited about these
shippable doors maybe I'm just looking
out for him better but I haven't found
any for a while until this part so all
she says it's cool well fine I go out of
my way to waste a shiv
get that and you just say mmm it's cool
I guess
grateful gosh that ignore all the
supplies that I got also from this but
man I'm more upset at that right thread
everybody's okay now all right all right
all right all right don't know today
gonna learn today about comics Wow there
are a lot of supplies in this place I
like it I like it a lot okay
sorry for the delay everybody but we're
good to go now yep yeah my white kid
come on kid move move kid kid you're
just like Ellie really Ellie now is the
time to sing near near noon in Iran here
where the hell are we going shoot you
toys yeah duck duck maybe those yeah
we're good no problems here they're
going yeah they are man that [ __ ]
truck it's been hounding us ever since
we got in this damn Sam what are you
doing nothing
Oh my bag is practically empty Oh
taking stuff it weighs nothing roll what
is it oh hey look jak and daxter you
have to come on this is this is made by
naughty dog who made jak and daxter so
look at this it's a little easter egg
her in he's real close okay let's go man
let's go buddies jak and daxter the
board game what would that even be I
haven't played a jak and daxter game
since jak and daxter - and I didn't play
any of the others so okay sorry about
that I also haven't played the Uncharted
series oh oh oh
Jesus you got to give me a warning more
warning about that man the tie-back kids
you may want to you know not stand out
in the open all right I'm gonna go
around
try to sneak up on them if I can't
bottle someone in the face where what
are we looking at there's one right
there one coming around that way yeah
get him get him okay yeah you go that
way okay one more whoa run at him come
on punch a punch okay you need help or
something or what I already got him yeah
geez this guy's gonna be a burden I can
tell that we did what do you mean we I
did it I did everything I polish the
[ __ ] out of all of them oh sorry kids I
mean I punched the poofy pants yeah out
of them mm-hmm mm-hmm
I punched the crap - doodles okay I
don't see any shippable doors no special
things all right let's go oh wait ham
nope it's all lies just filled with lies
Oh kids if you get in my way me first
thank you very much Ellie and whatever
your name was Sam I think chest high
walls just high walls you mean there's
gonna be enemies how strange
I never would imagine sorry I get
excited when I make a head shot cuz it's
so rare on young young young yo all
right where's the other one the other
ones up there I know there's one up
there where did he go he stopped moving
I probably got scared cuz his friend
just got his head blown off buddy
yup there there he is oh oh don't shoot
like that oh don't stand up really Billy
Joel there we go that's what I'm talkin
about
yeah well I'm talking about one bullet
one gun what was like three bullets but
by myself all day every day sorry I've
been obsessed with Kevin Hart recently
so
kind of been quoting him a lot if you
haven't watched Kevin Hart an you like
stand-up comedians he's good he's safe
God hears them and where'd you get that
see Firefly pendant really Firefly Lucas
Rios alright it's interesting shippable
doors oh they're trying to they're try
to talk to each other oh he's so shy
okay
we're finally inside is this a safe
place Wow interesting drawing boards
architecture stuff like that pretty cool
looking for supplies oh not fine and
much see what are we got here
their trial note but probably for just
someone ha la la
public trial bunch of teenagers group
killed a family wandered in a city
punished breaking codes procedure
supplies next week is going my turn
going home team huh interesting huh okay
so this is from after the quarantine
started and there was this sort of
quote-unquote trial that happened so
pretty interesting to see I mean I bet
there's a lot of story that I'm missing
out on by not reading all the notes but
I mean I'm trying to like I said in the
last episode or at least I think I said
in the last episode um I have I have a
sore responsibility to get through this
in a relatively good place I mean I'm
going to enjoy it and I try to enjoy it
but at the same time I need to keep the
story moving forward for everyone
watching
alright come on are we gonna talk about
this or what office welcome welcome
Ali's welcome what else we found a bit
of food though oh can I have some food
I'm hungry so how do you find blueberry
want some no blueberries we're safe or
someone have a farm out here so why
haven't you left been waiting for the
right opportunity yeah
yeah check
what what what were you doing why these
sons of [ __ ] everyday they
congregated down there garden that damn
bridge
why why bother guarding the bridge
anyways down to a skeleton crew mm-hmm
after sunset that's a window okay most
of them gone sneak right past them
alright I could work Oh sounds like a
plan it'll definitely work whatever you
say man Oh Luke you so cute glasses that
boy even cracked a smile she doesn't
seem bothered by all this so where were
you heading what a co-inky-dink we're
looking for you fireflies something
funny dogs it seems like there's a lot
of people putting their stock on the
fireflies these days yeah maybe there's
a reason for that
hmm you don't know where they are and
you're just gonna drag him across the
country to find him I tell you what
mm-hmm
I don't worry Don my brother you worry
about your girl Oh Oh what oh what easy
easy
we're looking for the fireflies too oh
oh I'm sorry oh this is us mm-hmm
there's an abandoned military radio
station just outside the city okey-dokey
any survivors from our group they're
supposed to meet us there tomorrow okay
you and your girl you won't join us it
goes down the night sounds good to me
let's do this I guess we best rest up
there all right
all right let's do this
enough waiting around man I don't know
when the last time Joel slept is
probably the early on in the game he
says it's time to go let's do this some
serious nighttime sneaking okay I think
I might be up to this challenge no
matter what you stick to me like glue
I'm ready I'm ready let's do this let's
go for it man okay all right you tried
this before yeah what's that kind of
thing okay there's just one guy there's
hope you know the way all right let's do
this man let's do this I'm ready I'm
ready I'm feeling it I'm loud and I'm
ready I'm just gonna go in there
screaming they won't know what hit him
well they probably will a crazy
screaming man charging at him from
straight ahead that's why I'm gonna be
I'm just worried I'm just worried that
this is gonna be a sort of stealth
mission where if I trigger one of them
like the whole game just ends so I'm
really gonna try to be very good about
sneaking about this okay turn off lights
I'm ready man
I'm ready I'm so ready I'm so ready okay
let's try to take him out quietly
okey-dokey
hey I'll follow your lead okey-dokey
yeah you better how you doing you better
follow my lead
get the one on the left there but don't
want to bother shipping him I'm just
gonna say oh you shoved him
really why can't I just get a knife I
would love to have just a big big ass
hunting knife that seems like it would
be ideal in this situation okay
oh hello were they shooting that out
there was that me did I trigger
something I don't think so
supplies thank you all right I'm full up
on health and everything I'm doing
pretty good actually okay they got a
giant-ass spotlight that seems to be
coming this way so it's a game of avoid
the spotlight right that's what we're
playing here okay I'll do my best
where oh I see it you want to shoot that
thing did you I missed it I didn't see
it do it again I missed it do it again
oh oh I'm behind this car just cuz you
can see my head clearly eliminated from
never mind
whatever whatever that such bull that's
baloney
all right well I guess we're doing this
the old-fashioned way since it doesn't
end the game actually
see maybe I could just shoot out that
light that would be nice yes whoa whoa
where did he come from
ah I'll try to duck Joel that's what I
was doing I'm gonna try to get that
light out boom there we go got him okay
cool
now we can move around all stealth
employed man that was dumb I was so
ready to be awesome and then of course
everyone was by expecting like horrible
derp markiplier doesn't know where to go
award he's doing ok this guy is gonna
get gonna get something to the face how
do I get to him it's hard to see ok I
see well you didn't see anything it's
pitch blackness how can you possibly see
anything
it's just feels like total darkness how
can anybody see in this place okay this
is that another one coming up Oh No get
out of here I can't sorry screw it
flashlights staying on him that's
doesn't that's my ally okay your allies
are in Westeros Khaleesi come on now
buddy come on now buddy
where's Ellie jumping on people's backs
this did not go I want ow
Oh Howie maybe it'd be best if I just
died because hey you're gonna be my
human shield all right
sound good I like having a human shield
it's cuz I'm almost dead whoa whoa stop
struggling man no nope finish it up
how is bolos swinging away Adam all
right whatever screw all that noise I
was playing so good before I might as
well just start over again whatever
whatever whatever whatever
really really whatever your name is
Hartford Dillon no that's where you came
from just trying to keep warm how's it
looking up there okay this time I'm
gonna not stand directly in the
spotlight and draw all the attention to
myself yeah see I'm like a ninja I see
it okay do it again you totally missed
missed again you're an awful shot there
you go all right so since it is pitch
black who are we dealing with over here
okay I just got to be very careful when
that's moving across I think I was
moving or something when came across my
head okay they can't see me I just got
to be not moving in the spotlight okay
here we go this is [ __ ] this is bull
this is for this friggin bull this is
the hall bull this is so much Oh screw
you buddy there we go okay at least the
spotlight is out now we can go around
them or something oh that's such bull
that's such baloney I can't even begin
to describe how much baloney that is all
right what are we dealing with over
where you gotta be joking me that's such
bull
oh my god this is like the level of bull
honky that this game is portraying right
now is unreal
whoa no you don't good shot
and waste ammo you got him there we go
I'm gonna actually switch out for no
that's not what I wanted
I'm gonna get the shotgun out could
screw this
still this is borked it's pitch
blackness
I'm I always duck ah whatever whatever
right okay okay I'm just gonna finish it
cuz I did something wrong so I'm at
fault
apparently die okay go headshot
okay this guy needs help here we go
got him down alright who else are we
dealing with who else we dealing with
you guys do agree that was kind of that
was kind of baloney that was kind of
malarkey there cuz I wasn't even in the
spotlight there we go jeez how tough is
this stop it or is that a different guy
okay have we got him all right god damn
that was ridiculous that was freakin
rude I should have turned my flashlight
on from the beginning that was such
baloney there I can't describe oh I
could turned off the generator oh that
would have been great if I could have
gotten to there whatever whatever
whatever
and here I was going on like I'm
actually playing good I'm actually doing
good under firm suddenly they have super
hearing super sight can see in the dark
can spot you from a mile away
you can see you all what the hell
where'd you come from still alive come
on everyone all right let's go up come
on me first
oh come on we're good Sam let's go
I'm gonna get left behind aren't I I can
already tell I'm getting a left behind
here they're gonna be like no no I'm
gonna go yes grab my hand comes there's
time there's time there's time there's
time Henry that's a big Henry a douche
Oh
Thank You Ellie you're the best there
was plenty of time okay get it up quick
quick like bunny big black bunny
Oh Ellie any minute now and I think that
gay would actually hold it
well whatever all those douches I knew
they were gonna I knew they were gonna
mmm Cheers everyone's out for themselves
how dare they are if we meet up with
them again I'm gonna give them a piece
of my mind
okay oh really really might we I'm gonna
booby-trap these sons of [ __ ] don't
stand up yet dick what was that over
that side what dude would was that maybe
you should check it out it's a smoking
can is it bacon cuz it can bacon Oh what
screw you then ow damn it oh come on
that was a head shot okay screw this
noise just standing out in the le le le
le mo Thank You Ellie brick this guy so
hard I don't know why my move didn't
work with the brick in the beginning
there but it's like some of the game
mechanics that I've been using for a
while suddenly decide to break I'm
blaming the game on this one and that's
what's supposed to happen
that's how it's supposed to it for
supplies go to your head yeah go to
theirs ha ha good one Joel you're so
clever I don't see any supplies I'm not
seeing anything Joel yeah I know I'm
being a poor sport I'm not the game's
not broken I'm just playing poorly and
I'm taking it out on the game which is
totally legitimate I could totally do
that and no one could question me except
the thousands and thousands of people
that are watching this sorry
all right moving forward
well those chains were certainly
effective let's go
I see the bridge yay why do they want us
so badly I mean we did kill almost all
of their friends run run run run epic
leaf up sweet bro running goal don't
fall down Joel a bad run run faster and
more more faster is better and yep
sweet so how many bullets you have left
the choice do we have
no it's too high you can't swim yes
anyway
oh that sounded brutal poor guys all
right oh we're still alive hooray
Henry look he's awake these dicks again
how dare they how do they find us he's
good everything's fine everything is not
fine Sam spotted you you guys are taking
quite a bit of water
he left us to die out there no you had a
good chance of making it and you did
yeah whatever
coming back for you putting him at risk
yeah whatever it was the other way
around what you would come back for us
no you say me too
we would have drowned
well that's actually a big move for Joel
because like at the beginning of this
game you could tell he was like totally
cold-hearted and he's kind of opening up
throughout the game which is kind of
really cool to see I mean I like that
because after 20 years of having nothing
and kind of losing his humanity and we
spotted you I mean man these guys radio
towers on the other side of this cliff
okay place is gonna be full of supplies
you gonna be really happy you didn't
kill me all right
whatever you say man whatever you say
see what we come up with really can I
sprint you cool yeah I'm fine
yeah let's confront a radio tower I'm
cooler than cool I'm gonna go this way
though well at least they trust me I
don't trust them do me mr. crab there we
go I can finally sprit again at least
they trust me yeah yeah sure cuz that
guy that guy over there's got to be like
I don't know probably in his 20s or
something like that he's a young guy so
I don't understand how old he was when
this all went down but he didn't see
what Joel saw he didn't lose with Joel
lost surprised whoa
that's more like it oh really you're
amazing the boat I found it is comics
for you I'm fine for you you don't care
you don't care I'm trying to be a good
well I'm not your father but Guardian
know some sort and you're just okay
whatever enough moping about okay I
don't need that I've got a better melee
weapon can't go this way
alright then whoa yeah yeah almost did
or maybe yeah
I think you're right hey see another big
moment for Joel he's growing up okay
whatever you say see oh great Oh sue
goes all the way through
I love the sewer what do we got man what
have we got brotherly manly whatever you
call it reparations manly recover Asians
what have you got bonding we're over it
like that man right it was men do it you
go I wish I could sprint it'd be nice
could I catch up with you guys by
sprinting and such with my sprint button
going quicker moving my legs in a quick
there we go sorry I forgot how to do it
for a little bit all right two ways are
we really splitting up should we should
we really is that what we should do this
does not seem like a good idea I know a
bloaters gonna just like pop out of
nowhere cuz that's what happens in these
places
ooh lookie supplies blood you're blocked
oh okay you can fit in this little hole
go um I work for me Ellie Oh deal with
it I've seen bigger
come on Ellie move on a time crunch here
got it Ally
good job come on it's nice that they're
conveniently placed it why couldn't you
have climbed through this whole getup
fit through there you're tiny
[Music]
voila you actually know what voila means
how did you learn wha well yeah okay
full on all that I need to craft some
stuff I'm just gonna have to see
everything yeah okay yes I remember yes
I'm gone for a few months and the world
doesn't waste any time going to [ __ ]
everywhere you turn they're infected and
unaffected trying to kill you mankind is
back in the food chain to the sewer seem
dirty safe pretty safe infants make it
easier to defend and if anyone gets in
the air I can lose them in the maze I
might not be tough but I'm quick I just
need to buy my time to get down here I
think I'll become a sewer Mole Man for a
while wish me luck have I seen the ish
before I think I recall that name hang
on I need to craft some stuff
um ba ba da ba ba Booey Baba Booey
I would love some more listen mode
difference I'm just saying love that
just smash some supplements down to fix
up my ears so I can hear better si make
another explosive probably make another
bomb probably need to do that okay all
right we're good we're gonna go good to
go all right I think that's gonna cut it
for this episode here so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
come here
[Music]
duh